all right guys bang bang I've got Darius
here with me Darius I thought a great
place for us to start is you guys have
this weather model explain what is the
weather model and why is it so important
to all the work that you guys do over at
42 macro yeah absolutely thanks again
for having me on pop always a pleasure
to be here so uh the number one thing
that our weather model helps us do is to
infuse volatility targeting into our
dynamic position sizing process in terms
of the asset allocation and Factor
exposure um recommendations that we make
for our clients so it really does help
us understand what the Maca regime is
with these other key macro Market
drivers are and how they've historically
influenced asset markets so that we can
have a forward looking real time now
casted Bayesian overlay to what's
actually happening out there so I'll
give you a quick rundown in terms of
what the model is currently seeing uh
we'll start with our real economy Cycles
so on the growth side we have growth
trending higher is expected to Trend
lower over the next 12 months when you
sort of um you know Source or you know
ask the wisdom of the crowd across all
the Wall Street economists when you look
at inflation it's in trending lower it's
expected to continue trending lower over
next 12 months employment the
unemployment rates trading lower it's
expected to Trend higher over the next
12 months you typically don't see a 90
basis point rise in the unemployment
rate outside of a recession so that's
Economist consensus you know implicitly
forecasting a recession there uh with
respect to corporate profits they
implied sales growth rate is trending
lower alongside the implied earnings
growth rate that's neither of those
numbers is particularly Draconian when
you look at fiscal policy which is
something we've been talking about all
year in terms of what's been you know
one of these incrementally supportive
aspects to the economy you know the
fiscal Sovereign fiscal balance has a
percent of nominal GDP that number is
trending lower and that 8.4 to 8.5
percent range that's a record non-war
non-recession budget deficit in the U.S
economy so clearly getting a lot of
fiscal support
um for the growth side but obviously
it's keeping inflation elevated relative
to the fed's Target uh the real
effective exchange rate has been
trending higher although I suspect it
may start to Trend lower if we start to
get worse inflation outcomes over the
next three to six months and so when we
transition to the right side of the page
with the which are the financial economy
Cycles we'll start with our 42 macro net
liquidity model we've talked about that
before that's the feds balance sheet
minus the treasury general account
diversity will facility balance uh that
number has been trading lower a global
liquidity proxy which we touched on uh
last week which is the global central
bank balance sheet plus global broad
money supply plus global FX reserves
minus gold that number's been draining
lower for a while now as well when we
look at credit through the lens of
domestic and Global uh broad money
supply those numbers are trending lower
those are both zeroth percentile values
in their respective time series uh you
typically don't see broad money supply
contract outside of the Great Depression
we don't have a monthly statistics for
that to compare but we do know that it
did contract albeit modestly in the
Great Depression uh interest rates uh
Benchmark policymates that's been
trading higher obviously a Fed May hike
uh one more time it's kind of a you know
kind of a 20 30 chance of that although
that number's probably gone down on the
Advent of these tools data today uh we
have the two-year nominal yield spread
versus the bench for our policy rate
that number has been trading lower it's
pricing in about 50 basis points there
uh in terms of aggregated U.S dollar
positioning we use that uh as one of our
fear components to track how much fear
is embedded in the market positioning uh
that number's neutral in terms of the
minus 12 non-commercial net link as I
said in a total open interest aggregate
a U.S rate positioning is in extreme
bearish positioning and then on the
greed side we look at aggregated
Commodities positioning across all the
19 components of the crb index that's an
extreme bearish position and then lastly
U.S equities uh is a neutral signal at
minus three percent uh net short in
terms of overall non-commercial net
length as a percent of total open
interest across all equity instruments
so when you look at this what is it
telling us kind of on a net basis in
terms of that liquidity but also what is
it showing us uh in in terms of these
asset prices and one of the things I
find fascinating is that obviously
inflation has come down we now see the
FED talking about maybe we still need to
go ahead and continue to hike interest
rates what what is this actually showing
us in terms of what they're likely to do
versus what they may be saying yeah so
there's two really important things that
investors should take away from this
table uh as it relates to what what to
do with their portfolio and again we
refresh this every morning for refer to
macro clients uh so number one is what
the three-month Outlook the rolling
three-month outlooks for uh for the
particular asset class and what that's
trying to do is Project excess
dispersion relative to the Baseline of
results that we've historically
experienced in the asset class and so
this current constellation of signals of
which each of these 20 features
contributes independently to each
independent asset class signal right now
this sort of current constellation is
saying hey this is a neutral time to be
along the stock market uh you know
relative to history and right now it's a
bad time to be alone the bond market
relative to history it's a bad time to
be loaned the dollar relative to history
it's a bad time to be long Commodities
relative history and it's a bad time to
be long Bitcoin relative to history and
what I mean by relative to history
because you typically experience more
volatility realized volatility larger
drawdowns when you're in a bearish
three-month Outlook condition in this
model we have back tests going all the
way back as far back you know at least
25 years for each of these asset classes
and when you're in a neutral setting you
kind of have this you know pretty normal
you know path Glide path for the asset
class and then when you're in a bullish
setting you have you know sort of
positive excess return dispersion
negative um dispersion with respect to
volatility so it's like a great time to
be invested in that particular asset
class the second thing I think investors
should take away from this table is what
how's it how does this table imply from
a factor dispersion perspective and so
as you see at the bottom there in the
middle
we are currently in the Goldilocks grid
regime that's where a situation where if
you look at the top left again that's
where growth's trending higher and
inflation is trending lower that's
historically been the best asset the
best of the regime for you know equities
risk assets Bitcoin Etc uh so that's uh
that's something to be note and to take
note of in terms of your you know how
you lean from a factor dispersion
perspective it's a little bit more
relevant for our hedge fund clients but
certainly it's important uh for for our
retail investor clients as well and then
the condition on that Goldilocks regime
is median and the reason it's only
medium as opposed to high or low is
because only one of the factors growth
in inflation is confirming the actual um
is confirming the actual um regime so as
you can see the implied next 12 month
real GDP Delta is pointed lower the the
consensus economists expect GDP to be
180 basis points slower in a year from
now than it currently is today and so
it's effectively saying hey look
growth's trending higher right now but
it's probably going to Trend lower over
the next 12 months but you're you're
getting confirmation from the implied
Delta on inflation so that's why it's a
medium if you're getting a double
confirmation from growth and inflation
to be a high conviction Goldilocks
regime you know feel very comfortable
going all in particularly on asset
classes that have a bullish signal and
then a low conviction Goldilocks regime
is when you have zero of the of the two
growth and inflation features uh
confirming the current the current setup
so now when we think about kind of this
setup that we're currently experiencing
one of the assets that a lot of people
who watch and listen to this screen care
about is Bitcoin you've got the
breakdown of kind of these pre-happing
Cycles through a number of the uh
previous havings and then obviously the
the bull markets that ensued what are
you showing here when you kind of go
through each one of these pre-halving
Cycles this episode is brought to you by
auradon they are a brand new startup led
by a number of Silicon Valley Legends
who just raised 81 million dollars to
build the future of Internet
infrastructure you're probably wondering
what that means let me explain there are
numerous new disruptive technologies
that are being adopted simultaneously
from blockchain to artificial
intelligence to zero knowledge
Technologies in order to ensure that
these Technologies thrive in this new
world we need new infrastructure and
that is where aardine comes in they just
launched their first product line called
teraflux which is a Bitcoin miner
powered by the world's first four
nanometer silicon chip technology these
air-cooled single phase and dual phase
immersion cooling miners have rivaled
speed and efficiency they have Superior
uptime and they'd leverage a brand new
innovation called Energy tune that
allows miners to dynamically adjust the
energy consumption and Bitcoin hash rate
based on demand response needs of the
electrical grids auradyne is an
ambitious company working on hard
problems I'm really impressed with them
and if you want to check out more you
can go to auradyne.com that's
a-u-r-a-d-i-n-e.com go check them out at
auradon.com today yeah absolutely so I I
think we you know I had a conversation
about this that I want to say back in
the spring or late winter early spring
about sort of the volatility that
Bitcoin tends to exhibit uh in the in
the Years leading out to havings
obviously having extended to be very
positive from a structural basis for the
for the asset class but there is a lot
of you know the the road to getting to
that having has historically been been
quite fraught and so you know on a
median basis when you look at the
November 20 2012 having the July 16 20
2012 2016 having and in the May 2020
having you know you see in the year
leading up to those havings is that we
tend to see a media at least a number of
drawdowns of consequence which is at
least 20 percent in our scoring uh you
tend to see on a median basis three of
those drawdowns and the drawdowns on a
median basis across all the havings and
there's total I want to say there's
about five to ten or sorry about eight
to ten of those total havings the
drawdown on a median basis is minus 27
percent so that's a long-winded way of
saying you can expect to see a you know
about three drawdowns of 27 or more
um in a pre-halving year and so that's
something we want to make sure investors
are aware of obviously we have source of
volatility in Bitcoin uh late last week
it's being reversed a little bit
obviously on the joke today that we're
getting today but generally speaking I
want investors to be very aware that hey
look as we get into the fall we get into
the spring we get into the first half of
next year when we still think a
recession is the modal outcome for the
U.S economy albeit in a flat
distribution of outcomes you could still
see some some volatility uh in the
Bitcoin price leading up to that having
that we're also equally answering
disability
now what's fascinating to me about this
is you're talking about multiple
drawdowns of over 20 percent kind of 27
uh kind of being that median but still
the cumulative return in the year
leading up to the having is 140 kind of
this run up into the having uh and
that's before you get to kind of what
most people would think of as the bull
market that really kicks off and we've
seen hundreds of percent how do we
evaluate whether we should anticipate
that 140-ish percent or so kind of
cumulative return in the year before the
having to occur this time versus not
occur are there certain signs that we
can look at that increase or decrease
the probability of it repeating yeah so
the number one uh Fair feature in my
perspective is is a trend higher in the
global liquidity side
um you know you typically see global in
particularly in the November 20 2012
into a lesser degree uh you know July
2016 prehabbing period you had the
global liquidity feature and asset
markets really really Rising pretty
pretty substantially you know I want to
say liquidity bottomed in 20 2011 uh and
and really started to rise linearly from
there from a global in terms of our
Global liquidity proxy it bottomed in
early 2016 and really was rising
linearly from there oh sorry in late
2015 rather and was rising linearly from
there in terms of our Global liquidity
proxy uh you just didn't see that in
2020 in 2019 we had you know pretty
Draconian liquidity conditions
throughout uh 2019 and obviously we saw
the worst of the of the pre having
drawdowns in that in that instance at
minus 48 and 53 and then the cumulative
return leading into the having in that
particular in that particular cycle was
only 20 right so there's you know I do
believe the liquidity feature in asset
markets is going to uh play a key factor
in whether or not we could have a you
know very positive cumulative return
despite having a decent amount of
volatility as opposed to and it's kind
of going to meander really from where it
kind of petered out in in April earlier
this year uh with a lot of volatility
ahead you know we still think Bitcoins
had it much higher over the long term
you know I think I'm you've done as much
research as anyone in terms of trying to
migrate institutional investors from
thinking about out 60 40 in terms of
their you know kind of Raa and Retail
type client flows to something that
looks more like 60 30 10 because I don't
believe that we are in an era where it's
going to get you're going to get paid
for being long for taking um long-term
um you know duration risk in the bond
market I'll throw a couple stats out to
um you know kind of include the program
which is we're still in a world where
you still have deeply negative term
premium and for those of you who may not
be familiar with that bond market
statistic term Premiere is what the
excess return you get for rope for
locking in your money for let's say 10
years 20 years 30 years as opposed to
constantly rolling over t-bills for that
amount of time it's a you know
statistical process to determine that in
terms of what's priced into the market
but right now if you go back and you
look at the long-term time series
history of term Premia it's about around
150 basis points plus 150 basis points
so you typically get you know basically
paid to take duration risk right now
it's negative it's negative 50 basis
points and so you know just going back
to the average could take you you know
200 basis points higher in the 10-year
without having any change in growth and
or inflation expectations in terms of
how bonds are priced so to me that's a
really boring sign in the context of our
secular inflation model which I believe
we talked about maybe last year or so
you know projecting the underlying trend
of core pce at three percent their cycle
two and a half to three percent in terms
of that range that's that's way higher
than it was in the previous decade which
is around 1.6 percent so and more
importantly two and a half to three
percent is above the feds two percent
inflation Target and so if they don't
change their inflation Target which we
happen to think they will in the next
couple of years if they don't change
their inflation Target they're going to
be constantly fighting the treasury
market constantly fighting asset markets
from the perspective of a interest rate
policy from the perspective of the
balance sheet policy we just don't think
that's politically palatable in a fourth
Turner
so I've talked maybe a year ago about
them changing that inflation Target from
two to three percent and I said look I'm
not saying that they're gonna do it
immediately I'm not saying that they're
going to 100 do it but there's a
increased odds that they're going to do
it people really laughed at me they said
I was stupid all kind of the CR you know
the critical uh views that you get from
the intelligent internet uh now I'm
seeing op-eds in major uh Publications
I'm seeing people talk about this more
and more how do we think about
handicapping like what are the odds that
they're actually going to increase it
and would it be like a two to two and a
half percent increase or could it be
like a two to three two to four percent
type Target increase on that inflation
number yeah so I think I mean the
central bankers and policy makers in
general particularly those in Western
age or Western economies that you know
some like the FED where everyone's
constantly eyeballing it every single
day and scrutinizing every decision that
it makes I don't think they're going to
make a big change overnight it's
probably going to come in two phases
we're going to be comfortable with
inflation settling out above two percent
and then officially when the
unemployment rate is high enough that we
have enough political pressure for the
FED to step in and have capitalized you
know these record budget deficits that
we spoke about earlier then they're
going to be able to say hey I think
three percent is a new too right think
about this Jackson Hole 2024
Jacksonville 2025 they're going to say
yeah we're fine with the you know
Meandering above two percent it'll
eventually get back to two percent
eventually and then you know assuming
the unemployment rate is is cooperating
at the time maybe you hit the Jackson
2025 Jacksonville 2025 or Jackson Hole
2026. that's when they just throw in the
towel and they say Okay three's the new
two because moving from three to two or
so yeah two three from two will allow
them again to do QE and to lower their
interest rate policy and ultimately the
big the big issue of our day is the just
the unfettered you know fiscal deficits
as far as the eye can see with no
recession projected which obviously is a
pretty ridiculous thing to project if
you're talking about 10 20 30 year
budget forecasts that we're talking
about 1.5 to 2 trillion dollar budget
deficits as far as the eye can see with
under no change in tax policy they're
supposed to be a pretty big change in
tax policy in January 2025 with the
expiration of the tax cuts and jobs tax
cuts but those aren't going anywhere we
know nobody's going to remove those once
you give people handouts and a fourth
turning not only do they clamor for they
want those handouts to remain but
they're going to clamor for more
handouts and so we know we're headed
down you know kind of a dark Rabbit Hole
populism that's just part of the part
and parcel of where we are in terms of
the longer term generational cycles that
my former colleague Neil house kind of
you know introduced us all to
it makes complete sense Darius where can
we send people to find you on the
internet or find out more about 42 macro
yeah I appreciate that Bob so uh come
check us out uh 42macro.com we're
actually relaunching our website and I
want to say next week or two weeks from
now so uh definitely come check that out
because I think everyone's going to
really enjoy a lot of the education uh
that we're going to put out there for
for the broader audience as well and
then in the meantime check us out on
Twitter 42 macro weather is my public
Twitter handle
awesome I appreciate it always I learned
something today's no different we'll
definitely do it again in the future
absolutely brother thanks again man